So joining me now is uh Raymond Ibraim.
He is a distinguished Middle East
expert. He is an author and scholar
providing insights into Islam and the
West and the ongoing challenges facing
Christian communities worldwide. He's
also the author of a number of books. Uh
the the defenders of the west uh sword
and scimitar uh also uh crucified again
exposing Islam's new war on Christians,
the al-Qaeda reader, the battle of
yarmmuk and the two swords of of Christ
which is uh now uh getting ready to
release. So you can pre-order that right
now. Raymond, thanks so much for making
time for me today. I do appreciate it.
>> Yeah, sure. Good to be with you, Pete.
So, I I came across your YouTube channel
uh a couple of uh weeks, maybe a month
and a half ago or so, and I've just
watched, I think, every episode uh even
the really long ones. Uh and uh I I
apologize for not having uh been aware
of your work before, but you've been
doing this for a very long time, since
like 2011, I want to say. So, if we
could just condense like your 20 years
of of research and expertise along with
like 1500 years of Islam into like 15
minutes, we'll be we'll be fine. We'll
be good to go. Sure.
>> Um, so let's start with the thing that
uh prompted me to reach out to you
actually, which was about the Christian
persecution uh that's going on around
the globe. So you've been monitoring
this for 20 years, right? And you've
been doing these monthly updates. I am
embarrassed. I've never heard of these
before. So tell us first like where do
you get this information from? And then
we'll get into sort of the what the data
shows.
>> Sure. So um the Muslim persecution of
Christians has been one of my fortees in
that I've been really following it for a
long long time actually over more than
20 years. My my first published article
on that topic was probably 20 years ago.
But what you're referring to in 2011 is
when I started compiling reports which
I've still been doing for so for 14
years monthly reports. And um I get this
information um from a a variety of
sources. Sometimes it's the mainstream
media. If the attack is spectacular and
graphic enough and they're forced to
cover it, I'll use I can use some of
them. But more often than not, it's sort
of smaller organizations, human rights
groups, and sometimes individuals
including on the ground and um often in
different languages like Arabic that I
get it from because as you can imagine,
it's not exactly a topic that's uh being
as you mentioned, you know, you don't
know about it and it's not really your
fault because uh the media doesn't want
to talk about it even though it's really
a big topic. Um so yeah, I've been doing
that for a long time. my 20 uh 2013 my
book crucified again is devoted to it
and it really gets into the doctrines
and the history and ties the past and
the present together and you know from a
personal level it all started because my
family comes from Egypt where Coptic
Christians so we have a long uh
appreciation of Islam and uh you know
how it behaves visav the infidel so even
in my youth I already was hearing
stories and quite acquainted with this
phenomenon and Um, yeah, that that's
that's it in a nutshell.
>> So, you were born in America, but these
were stories that you heard growing up
from your family that came from Egypt.
>> Correct. Yeah. I mean, the first time I
was introduced to this topic was in my
very early youth from family members and
relatives who would visit and and I also
visited the region and um saw it
firsthand as well. So, um yeah, that's
the sort of the genesis of my interests,
but since then, I've more, you know,
focused on it from a more professional
kind of level.
>> Yeah. Uh well, you know, if it's
something that you're interested in and
you can get paid to to research it, like
that sounds like best of both worlds. Um
so the one that one of the stories that
did break through Nigeria recently and I
heard you talk about this on one of your
episodes that it was framed and when I
when you said it, I was like, I had no
idea. This is how this is what I thought
too. And I follow the news pretty
closely. I mean, I've been doing this
now, you know, 20 years. I follow the
news really closely. And I had heard
this, oh, it's against the the farmers
and the herdsmen and that's the fight.
And there was this massacre over like
between farmers and herdsmen. And I was
like, huh, okay. Well, that's weird.
But, you know, I'm not I I don't know
anything about Nigeria and their
politics or land use disputes. But that
wasn't what really this is about, right?
>> No, not at all. That's exactly how the
media and politicians like to dissemble.
Um, you know, there's a kernel of truth
to it that most of the attackers are
herdsmen and nomads. They're known as
the fani and most of those being
attacked are sedentry farmers. But
behind the scene, the fanis are Muslim
and the sedentry farmers are Christians.
And the fani habitually um articulate
their raids as a jihad. I quoted once a
a a uh a Christian nun nun a sister
sister sister something I forget her
name from Nigeria and she said it's hard
to call this a land dispute when those
attacking are wearing black like ISIS
chanting Quranic phrases and and saying
kill the infidels and Akbar. So it's
absolutely a jihad from the Muslim side
and they are focusing on Christians and
sometimes Muslims also get killed
because a lot of times there's a
moderate Muslims living amongst
Christians in these villages and the
Muslims have even you know the groups
and the Islamic groups there like Boo
Haram and other Islamic terror group
have rationalized that you can kill
those Muslims because they're they're
just as good as infidels because they
live with Christians and you should hate
Christians according to Islamic teaching
like Quran 6040 and so forth. So yeah,
it's absolutely a religious persecution
of Christians. A lot of human rights
groups call it a genocide.
>> Um, you're probably referring I spoke to
a priest there and you know, he
confirmed everything that I knew. I
again because I've been following the
persecution of Christians in general for
a long time. Nigeria has definitely
been, you know, at the four of that
because you can't escape it. There's
more Nigerian Christians get killed than
any Christian in general. I think the
number is uh two per one per one every
two hours in general. Uh so 12
Christians every single day in Nigeria
365 days a year are slaughtered for
their faith and thousands of churches
have been destroyed. Um but yeah, you
don't uh those black lives don't matter
apparently because they're Christian and
there's no political agenda that can be
used to, you know, to to to exploit this
with. So yeah.
>> Yeah. And the priest was asking for
attention, asking for help. The I
believe he said the Nigerian government
is not helping to defend them. Um
I I mean it just it seems I don't know
it seems I don't want to say hopeless
but it seems it's very frustrating. Um
you know it's discouraging.
>> Yeah it's all it seems surreal actually.
Yeah, the the government has been well
known to it's not only that there's
multiple anecdotes that have come from
local Christians including Christian
leaders and or priests and bishops from
those regions saying that you know the
military is in the region but once the
terrorists come they just leave or turn
a blind eye and even worse there's been
um actual instances where people say the
military provides them with cover and
yes they did disarm uh you know the
people of Nigeria but the terrorists
always have weapons for some reason
these guys were operating supposedly
illegally. So for a lot of Christians in
Nigeria, this is actually intentional
and the government is somehow in cahoots
with the some nefarious agenda that is
exploiting Islamic jihadism v these poor
Christian farmers. Remember Nigeria is
about half Christian, half Muslim. And
in in a way it's also a reflection of
what happens when you have you know
equal forces of Muslims and Christians
or non-Muslims living side by side. It's
interesting because there's a whole
dynamic about numbers and when the
numbers are very few, you know, let's
say in America, how Muslims behave is a
certain way and then when they grow like
in Europe, then they behave another more
aggressive way until you get to what you
have in Nigeria. And then when of course
it's 90 or 100% Muslim then is, you
know, Christianity snuffed out
altogether like in Saudi Arabia for
instance.
>> Is that doctrinal like or is that just
is that just like hey this works, this
is a strategy, we'll just employ that.
Yeah, I mean it's it fundamentally
inherently it is doctrinal. Islam
teaches, you know, I'm doing a deep dive
again in one of the what I consider the
most dangerous doctrine of Islam and
basically in a nutshell commands Muslims
to hate non-Muslims intrinsically not
because of what they do. And there's
these, you know, leading jurists like
Tya who say even if a non-Muslim is good
to you, you have to hate him. And
there's other Muslim clerics saying if
you're married to a Christian or Jewish
woman, which is permissible according to
Islam, you have to hate her, but you can
enjoy her carnally, but you have to show
her that you hate her. So hatred for the
infidel is an ironclad aspect. I, as I
mentioned, Quran 64, anyone can look it
up if they have an actual uh accurate
translation. It it tells Muslims, you
have an example in Abraham, Ibraim um
because he told his people, we enmity
and hatred shall last between us until
you become a Muslim. So that is that's
the you know the bedrock um verse of the
of the hostility but beyond and above
that specifically in regards to
Christians and Jews is Quran 9:29 which
uh basically says fight the people of
the book which Muslims have defined as
Christians and Jews um until they either
pay tribute or become Muslim. Jiza is
the tribute or they become Muslim or you
fight them to the death. Okay. And
there's other verses which literally say
infidels are they who say Jesus is uh
the son of God. Infidels are they who
believe in a trinity. And to be an
infidel, people don't understand this.
The word keer in the singular is
basically to be a default enemy of
Islam, a subhuman essentially. You're
not even, you know, you you just exists
to be conquered, trampled upon,
subjugated, killed, whatever until you
convert. Okay. So absolutely there's a
doctrinal aspect to it. And even more
specifically uh the details come out in
what's called the conditions or the
stipulations of Omar. And this is a
document that is purportedly was written
between the the second khif Omar and the
conquered Christians of Jerusalem.
Though there's some debate it could be
the second Omar in the 8th century. But
be that as it may, it basically uh tells
Christians you have to abide by all
these rules. Okay. All of which by
modern day standards are considered
inhum inhumane and absolutely have no
fairness or equality. You can't build
churches. You can't repair churches. You
can't uh let a Muslim see a cross or a
Bible. We don't want to hear your praise
or singing. If if uh if your pe if a
Christian wants to convert to Islam and
we could, you know, if Muslims convince
him one way or the other, you can't
interfere. You have to stand up and give
your seat to a Muslim if they want it.
You have to open your door to Muslim
travelers if they want it. So that kind
of thing was historically implemented
but it still informs the mentality of a
lot of Muslims because that's the proper
place of a Christian. He has to be
subdued and a secondass citizen at best
which is why in many ways this is
happening not just in Nigeria but
essentially in any Muslim country that
has Christian populations. And I'll
close it just by saying that Open Doors,
kind of a human rights organization,
publishes a report annually called World
Watch List, which ranks the 50 worst
nations in the world that persecute
Christians. And habitually, I've been
reading it for well over a decade. Um,
every annual report about 37 38
sometimes more of the 50 nations are
Muslim nations. So, I think that really
underscores what we're talking about
here.
>> I want to I have the list. Um, number
one, I guess this is from the most
recent one, the annual report. You you
ran through these numbers. North Korea
was number one, which I kind of found
surprising for some reason. I don't
know. I guess I didn't really ever
consider it, but I guess, not to defend
the North Koreans, but they kind of
oppress everybody. So, I guess it makes
sense that the Christians would be on
that list, too, just because probably
everyone's on that list.
>> Yeah. It's not that they're pinpointing
Christians. just that anyone who dares
go against the supreme leader
>> who's a who's a cult figure essentially
is the enemy
>> you know and but one thing to keep in
mind because you're right everyone gets
shocked sometimes when I talk about
Islam you know the persecution
Christians by Muslims people go well the
worst country is North Korea has nothing
to do with Islam and the simple reply to
that is yeah but that is also an
aberration you know it's not endemic to
Korean society look at South Korea where
Christianity flourishes so it's not a
part of Korean culture or or anything um
intrinsic to it. It's just one guy,
okay, who is a megalomania megalomaniac,
right? And if and when he's gone,
everything can completely change.
>> In Islam, that's not the case. It's not
this or that group, this terrorist
leader or or whatever. It's just the
entire nation. It's the entire
civilizational block. Which is why when
you look at that list, those 37 38
countries, Muslim countries, they're
completely different. Yeah. They're
different racially. You have like Turks
and Arabs and Persians and East Asians,
Indonesians, the Maldives, you have
subsaharan Africans. Um, and they have
different socioeconomic situations and
governments and yet they all do the same
sort of thing. Why? Because it's Islam.
>> That is the common denominator. It's
what you were running through earlier.
It sounds a lot like uh supremacy a
supremacy ideology uh of all the
different
>> That's a good way to see it actually.
>> Yeah. like we're here, you're all there,
and so therefore we get to do all of
these things to you just based on our
religion. Basically,
>> Islam is inherently a supremacist
religion. You know, here in the West,
everyone is so obsessed with racial
supremacy and that kind of idea, but
there is such a thing as religious
supremacy and it's alive and well in the
Islamic world.
>> Yeah. Um All right. So, is there
anything else on the the Christian
persecution issue here before? Oh, there
was one other thing I wanted to ask you
about. Canada, what's going on up in
Canada? Um, like I heard you mention
this. I think it was on your your
website as well, uh, which I should
mention is raymond. Uh, that's with a d
raymond uh ibrahim.com.
And, u I'll give that out as well before
and after here. Um, but I was reading
that apparently like there's a whole
bunch of churches getting burned in
Canada. Once again, member of the media
here, I've seen nothing about this at
all.
>> Well, yeah, because it's not reported.
And if it is, they'll they'll pretend
it's not arson. U but yeah, Canada, this
little country which supposedly is
liberal and free and uh etc. has become
sort of the epicenter of burn churches
even even more so than in Europe. The
fact is, you know, before we delve into
Canada, a lot of people don't realize
that all throughout the world, including
in the United States, and increasingly
so, not just Canada, churches are like
almost daily attacked.
>> Okay? And in in in a lot of vile ways,
feces smeared on them, you know, people
urinating on altars, breaking crosses,
decapitating statues. That's like a I
mean, if we talk globally, several
several churches experience that every
single day. Um, so it's definitely a
growing thing. But in Canada, it's
really bad. And it got really bad a few
years ago. there was an actual spate of
attacks. That's when the media kind of
spoke about it. There was something like
30 or 40 attacks that on churches in
maybe in a month. And the pretext was
these graves. Maybe you heard about
these native graves that were found. And
the long story short is supposed the
idea came out that Catholic missionaries
were somehow torturing uh natives and
burying them to hide the evidence.
>> And that's been debunked continuously.
Okay. I mean, it's it's just ridiculous.
Absolutely. Um, and but it's been used
as a pretext to go on a church burning
spree. And and the way to understand how
this is not even about that, because if
it was about that, you would attack,
okay, Catholic churches, that's the
logic. They're the ones who supposedly
did this. Seems all sorts of churches.
>> Seems logical. Yeah.
>> Right. Including Coptic churches, the
same churches in Egypt that are being
attacked by Muslims. Coptic people go
live in Canada and they probably started
immigrating there three decades ago at
most. They have nothing to do with these
native graves which were supposedly
buried a century ago and their churches
are being burned uh by the same people.
And um I think the interesting thing
about that to me is a lot of people they
always they're they're starting to sense
that there's some sort of congruity
between Islam and what's called the
left. Okay. And yeah, there is. I mean,
for example, attacks on churches. that
like I said is something that's very
normal by Muslims in the Islamic world
and also very much in Europe constantly
happening. Um but also you see the left
is doing it as well and maybe even more
so at this point. And so you kind of
start seeing okay while the left is sort
of a representative of this sort of
extreme liberalism and sexual
promiscuity and confusion and you know
the wokeness and Islam is patriarchal.
You know, no one understands how are
they in in cahoots. Well, it's because
the enemy of my enemy is my friend and
their ultimate enemy is Christian
civilization. And you can see it in
their constant attacks on churches. I
mean, that's just one example, but
there's other examples that we can see
and how they both respond in the same
way to free speech and criticism. Okay?
Uh we know about Islam's blasphemy laws.
For example, if you say anything that
can be, you know, uh, construed as
negative or critical about Islam,
especially its prophet, well, you can
get yourself killed. Well, here in the
West, we're starting to notice that if
you speak and say just the truth and
things that go against what the left
wants you to believe, you can go to
jail. In fact, most recently, I learned
that a Spanish priest, a Catholic priest
in Spain is now facing three years in
prison because of Islamophobia because
he said something critical about Islam.
And I just looked into it and what he
said is actually just what I'm saying
basic truisms historical doctrinal
truisms and because of that the left
just like Islam is now going to punish
him. So yeah, there's definitely a
massive assault on Christianity and
Western civilization in general. And um
it's it's by what's called the left.
That's who's really spearheading it. And
in many ways, Islam and Muslims are
their sort of foot soldiers. But they
have the same common enemy. And it's all
being dissembled because the media works
for them, of course. And um whether it's
the persecution of Christians in Nigeria
or whether it's uh you know what's
happening here in Canada.
>> Yeah. It's the Ben Shapiro calls it the
omnic cause. Uh and uh the the quote
I've been using is you know the issue is
never the issue. The issue is always the
revolution. It doesn't matter what the
particular issue of the day is. Just
does it help it tear down Western
civilization. And if we can attack those
foundations, then we all win. And it
doesn't matter. We'll sort our
differences out afterwards.
>> Exactly. And that's what I that's what I
was alluding to about Nigeria and black
lives don't matter there. Right.
>> So here in America, well, yeah, we can
explo we'll exploit one black death,
George Floyd and destroy everything
because we're acting like we care. But
when it comes to hund tens and hundreds
of thousands of blacks being slaughtered
with machetes and burned alive because
of their faith, well, we won't even
mention it. And that right there proves
to you that this isn't about being
humanitarian or good or woke. It's about
exploiting all these pretextes for their
own agendas, which is, like you said,
the destruction of the West.
So when you're discussing and I'm
probably got a like I'm I'm thinking
we'll do three well this will be three
segments now. So and I'll edit this uh
for the radio program just this part out
but for October 7th what you just
described with the attacks on Christians
in Nigeria and all over. I can't help
but notice there seems to be a bit of a
similarity in some of the tactics uh
that you've discussed going back
throughout history in the you know from
the Crusades up to the present what we
see in Nigeria right now and what we saw
in Israel on October 7th when Hamas
crossed the uh their you know broke
through the fence line and murdered
1,200 people. Um, is that like we're not
like that's not a coincidence, right?
>> No, no, no. Anyone who's familiar with
the true history of Islam will realize
that the continuity between what you
just described is staggering and um
unwavering. Okay. So, uh you know, I
have it right here. whoever is
interested my main book that I wrote
Sword and Scimitar 14 centuries of war
between Islam and the West which I I
document from the very beginning you
know the hostilities and violence and
warfare between Muslims and Christians
and everything that we're seeing today
was on display then even more so when
they tell you that you know ISIS or the
Islamic State is hijacking Islam and
that's not how Muslim Islam has acted
and Islam was a beacon of light in the
medieval era etc etc those are again
once again all lies or what I've dubbed
fake fake history which is more
dangerous than fake news because it sets
up false archetypes that people you know
see reality through. Um, if anything,
ISIS is just a small meager reflection
because what we had back then was
massive caliphates, okay, that could
marshall enormous resources and manpower
and unleash them on their enemies, the
infidels. And all, you know, most people
don't realize, just, you know, to
summarize this and give you an idea,
what's today called the heart of the
Islamic world, okay, the Middle, they
call it Mina, Middle East, North Africa
acronym, the Arab world essentially,
that was all Christian. Not only was it
Christian in the seventh century, it was
more Christian than Europe. When we
think of the past and we think of
Christendom, you always think of Europe.
People don't realize that in the seventh
century and before that, the primary
heart of Islam, of Christianity, I'm
sorry, Christendom was all of North
Africa, especially Egypt, especially
Syria, especially what we call Turkey,
Asia Minor. This is why Constantine
moved the capital all the way to uh New
Rome, Constantinople, which was
essentially in Turkey today. uh that's
where all the you know that's where and
of course that makes sense because
that's where Christianity was born in
the Middle East. So obviously that area
was Christianized a lot earlier than
distant Europe anyway all of that was
conquered by Muslims. So today when you
speak about the Arab world well that is
conquered Christian territory. That's
why there are still Coptic Christians in
Egypt and Christians Assyrians in Iraq
and Syria. Uh because they're the ind
indigenous inhabitants and they were all
Christians at the time. So yeah, the
whole thing was a long warfare, a long
jihad. It was doctrinally backed by the
verses I mentioned, violence against
Christians and Jews and conquest, giving
them three options, etc. And the
atrocities that the Muslims engaged in,
and they're in the book, um, you know,
beggar of the imagination. In fact,
ISIS, the key to understand ISIS is
they're they are familiar with the
history of Islam and they're consciously
trying to emulate it. In fact, people
don't realize that a lot of their words,
what they used to say, um were actual
formulaic phrases stripped from early
Islamic conquerors and jihadists and
khalifs and sultans, you know, like when
they when they would say um uh we've
tasted American blood and none is
sweeter. Well, that that comes from bin,
the sword of Allah in the first battle
against Christian Europe, the battle of
Yarmmuk in 636. He said, we've tasted
Roman blood, none tastes better, and
we're here to kill you unless you
convert. So it's definitely the the
continuity is there and like I said
unwavering but the fact that most people
don't know that is once again a
reflection of how well the liars have
been at concealing this and in this case
it would be the first we spoke about the
media now we're talking really about the
academics. Yeah, that's so I will tell
you like I saw the line uh in your write
up on the battle of Yormuk where it was
and I I remember the line being uttered
many many times after by leaders of uh
Islamic countries or terrorist
organizations and they would say things
like uh you love life more than or we
love death more than you love life and
that comes from that that same battle.
It's a call back and
>> uh and that's you know inspiration and
to your point I remember so after 9/11
>> I did a series on Islam in 2001 as a
young reporter and part of that was to
go talk to local uh Islamic center imam
and uh and he told me and I was young
and naive he said Islam means peace and
I said oh oh isn't that nice you know
okay and I found out years later that
and correct me if I'm wrong, peace
through the submission to the will of
Allah, which I think is a different kind
of peace than what I thought he meant
when he said Islam means peace. Is that
accurate to you?
>> Yeah, that's accurate. And it's also a
word play because in in Arabic, you
know, several related words are formed
from the same trilateral root,
triliteral root, three roots. And so the
word slm salama means peace. But then
how you change the vowels. So Islam,
it's the same three letters, right?
Yeah.
>> Means you get submit. You get peace
through submission.
>> So Islam is an imperative. The word
Islam is an imperative. I can say to you
Islam,
>> which I'm basically saying submit.
>> And the idea behind it is in once you
do, you will have peace and once you and
if you don't, you will have war.
>> Uh Raymond Ibrahim, thank you very much
for your time. I do appreciate it. I
could talk to you for a lot longer, I
suspect, but I've already kept you a
little bit past your time. Thank you for
your generosity with your time. Uh, and
would love to do it again someday.
>> Sure. Sounds good, Pete. Thanks a lot.
Thank you.